Oh
the first person to even come up with
the idea was in the late 19th century
the great Swedish chemist are hey nice
who later won the Nobel for other work
did some back-of-the-envelope
calculations about what would happen if
we burned all the coal that we were at
that point beginning to build burn and
oddly enough his numbers come not that
far from what the biggest supercomputers
on earth are now cracking out but really
nobody paid any attention until really
the 1980s that's when we had computers
big enough to begin effectively modeling
the climate and that was the first point
at which scientists really began to
sound the alarm probably Jim Hansen for
the NASA scientist before Congress in
June of 1988 saying global warming is
real is as good a point as any to kind
of pick as the starting date for the
global warming era
we wouldn't be in the same position we
might still be going to have to deal
with some mild effects of climate change
but will be well on our way now to
having made the transition away from
fossil fuel it's am it's going to turn
out to be a great great historical shame
that we didn't pay attention when we
knew what was going on you know I wrote
the first book about all of this 21
years ago in 1989 the time I was 27 and
believed that people would read the book
which they did it was translated into 24
languages I think and then they would
act and solve the problem which they
didn't the only thing we didn't know 20
years ago when I wrote the end of nature
was how fast is this going to happen
where is the red line and being human
you know we all hope that it was some
ways away so it would be somebody else's
problem to deal with those hopes have
been steadily evaporating for the last
10 or 12 years it's been very clear that
the earth was more finely balanced than
we realized and that we were seeing
change happening ahead of schedule and
on a larger scale than we expected but I
think if you were looking for a date
summer of two thousand and seven when we
saw the very rapid melt of sea ice
across the Arctic was really the point I
mean I spent that summer getting phone
calls from scientists I've known for a
quarter century who have always been
worried and concerned but all of a
sudden were panicked we're saying no
matter what physical phenomenon we look
at we're seeing this kind of violent
flux
Oh everything is relative we're not
going to stop global warming obviously
we've already warmed the planet a lot
that's what this new book earth that's
the point it makes you know this is
already underway and in a big way but
what's bad can always be made worse if
we don't act soon then the stakes are
really civilizational in scale so far
we've raised the temperature about 1
degree with another one degree locked in
from emissions we've already put into
the atmosphere one degree has been
enough to melt the Arctic two degrees
will do more damage but if we don't act
very quickly scientists are quite clear
that the temperature will go up four
five six degrees in the course of this
century and that's just change of a sort
that we've never even contemplated